[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight i wanted to take you through
uh what is without a doubt
the most important uh you know contest
in america uh the united states
chess championships uh however i'm not
gonna go over
the games of wesley so who did walk away
with the championship trophy this year
uh but i'm gonna go over the games of
one bobby fisher
because wesley so's performance in the
2020 championships
was pretty historic he was two points
off a perfect score
by my counts uh but you know not to be
outdone
bobby fischer was not two points off a
perfect score he actually did get a
perfect score
in this 1963 64 championship and
i wanted to take you through a few games
that really
show the just total domination that
bobby fischer had over his competition
in this tournament he had to win
11 games in a row to get the perfect
score and over 11 games
every aspect of your chess is going to
be tested as it was for bobby fischer so
let's see
some of his competitive matchups how he
actually came out on top
and what had to be done to get that
historic 11
and 0 score all right jumping right into
it
uh one of his main competitors in the
event was one
larry evans a u.s champion in his own
right
and i think evans did end up actually
getting second place in the tournament
with a very very good score as well
but of course not not quite not quite as
good as
11-0 that bobby put up this year uh so
let's take a look
and see what happened we had e4 by bobby
fischer e5
and then in round two of the event
that's
the the round that this game was played
uh bobby had won
sort of a long and arduous uh first
round game
uh it went down to this this end game
and bobby managed to outplay his
opponent
and perhaps with that long and arduous
victory in mind bobby decided he was
going to do something
a little bit differently right you know
why slog it out in a long end game when
you can just play the king's gambit
and make sure one way or another the
game is going to get interesting so
of course these days the king's gambit
it's it's a huge uh
debate whether or not this is totally
sound i think most of the top players
these days kind of agree
with good play black can get a little
bit of an advantage
against this move how can black get an
advantage well white put a pawn on
f4 and that square is attacked and that
square is not defended
so larry evans decided he would capture
the pawn for free
and that is generally what they say is
the way
to start scoring for an advantage here
uh bobby plays
the very very combative bishop c4 knight
f3 is a bit more common these days
controlling h4 and g5 two critical
squares
for black and after bishop c4 uh larry
evans
attempted to sort of refute this move
right most players go knight f3
to defend these squares bishop c4 does
not defend those squares
and larry evans decided to come after
bobby here with the move queen h4
check just directly checking the king
forcing a concession here
um and i think these days most players
are not actually playing this move queen
h4
it gets into some really really crazy
lines but
maybe this is not the safest path for
for black to continue but it is what we
see in this game
alternatives by the way just the simple
knight f6 uh
and even d5 is a playable move here with
some ideas
of sacrificing this pawn back for quick
play
in the center but in this game queen h4
check going after the king
uh of course g3 would be unplayable if
f takes g now blight is in the middle of
a pretty unfortunate pin
so king f1 is sort of the only move for
white here
and now black continues to sort of try
and hold on to everything
with the move d6 and this is sort of
the the attempt at refuting the king
stamp it that that larry is doing here
right
black is attempting to keep everything
right
black checks the white king so the white
king can no longer castle black is
defending
this f4 pawn with the queen trying to
hold on to it and black is also not
willing to sort of give this pawn back
with these sacrifices like d5 that i
just mentioned uh
stuff like d5 stuff like not going queen
h4 that's gonna be a much
safer approach for black but with queen
h4
and d6 like i said black wants to have
his cake and eat it too
which against bobby could be a recipe
for disaster getting a bit greedy
uh bobby just continues with natural
development with knight c3
and i think that's pretty instructive
here a lot of players
you know in their heart are really
wanting to play sort of wild and crazy
gambits
but i think a common mistake that a lot
of you know amateur level
players make when they play these crazy
gambits is you know that they play
bishop c4
and they sacrifice their pawn with f4
and they say okay now
now i have to go checkmate but first and
foremost
the idea of any gambit is to get rapid
development
and rapid you know an accelerated
version
of getting your pieces into the game so
knight c3
very very good move just developing the
pieces
we saw bishop e6 by larry evans
now uh black is willing to offer up a
trade of pieces
he's played d6 kept his pawn on f4 and
now
it's just a question of weathering the
storm by bobby fischer here right
can black defend these loose squares
around the king especially in particular
this d5 square
of course bishop takes e6 would be a bad
move by bobby f takes e6
and then something like e5 is going to
come and black will be able to hold on
to this pawn
but queen e2 is the choice by bobby
fischer in this game
keeping pieces on the board and trying
to
accelerate the development even further
bobby fischer isn't really worried
about the trade of the bishops but now
if black does want to trade
notably it's going to come at the cost
of activating white's
queen that's what these gambits are all
about it's not about check meeting right
away
it's about getting rapid development uh
in the game
larry evans chose not to capture on c4
which is very very understandable
no need to draw the white queen into the
game and instead
perhaps worried about the move knight d5
or even knight b5
the move c6 comes a very sensible move
just
to control some squares now we finally
see
the other knight get developed with
tempo on this queen and the queen comes
all the way back
to e7 and now we see d4
and what has bobby fisher gotten in
exchange
for this pawn on f4 well he's got this
nice
central pawn duo that everybody tries to
aim for
both of the knights are developed to the
most natural squares this bishop is
threatening to come out to f4
and this bishop for the moment is well
placed on c4 or after bishop takes c4
has played in the game now the queen
will be well placed on c4
there's this principle about not
developing the queen out too early
but that principle has sort of a very
important caveat
right if you develop your queen too
early it tends to be bad
but why is that it's because the queen
is going to get pushed around
by the minor pieces so in this case it's
very very unclear
how the minor pieces are actually going
to attack the white queen
and so because of that black has no way
to exploit the queen being out early
and that just makes it a very very
active piece for
white now so far black has been playing
very very greedy black has tried to keep
everything tried to keep the pawn on f4
tried to keep the center tried not to
give up a pawn with d5
either and with that in mind what do you
think the natural follow-up is
for black here what what should black
play i turn the question to you chat
room
how can black play in this particular
position
in particular the question is really
about this
f4 pawn and so yeah the chat is saying
knight f6 get the pieces out
and there are really two competing ideas
here number one you can play something
like knight f6 something like knight d7
something like knight a6
some developing move to try to get the
pieces out or you can play the move g5
and try to keep your pawn
or you can play the move g5 and
in this particular case playing knight
f6 i think would be a pretty big mistake
for black objectively probably it's not
the worst move
of all time but thus far black has been
making these tiny little concessions in
order to try to keep the material right
we saw the queen
come out to h4 and then lose a tempo
after knight knight f3
we've seen the pawn and go from d7 to d6
allowing white this extra central space
not kind of combating that earlier on
and we've seen black trade off this
bishop and
activating the the white queen so now
it's sort of
uh you know at a point where black needs
to make his play a little bit more
consistent than knight
f6 right you can't make all these
concessions and then say
okay fine now you can have now you can
have my pawn back
notably by the way if you were thinking
you're getting this guy
the tactics just don't quite work out in
your favor here i think i
oh maybe they maybe they do i didn't
look
too deeply at this but i'm assuming this
move is is good enough
and there's just no way to defend this
knight if you go f6
or f5 rather i can still take it
so moves like knight f6 they are not
going to be
what black should be doing here black
needs to play consistently if you made
all these concessions to try to keep
your pawn
then now is not the time to give up you
you should try to keep the pawn
so larry evans does play the move g5
which i think is the most thematic
choice
now the question for bobby fisher
is what do you do you've gotten your
great central pawn duo you've gotten
your knights out to the most natural
squares you've got a pretty active queen
as well but there are still some
problems right this bishop
for one is a bit of a problem this king
is also a bit of a problem
because it's interfering with the rook's
access to
the center of the board right it's
keeping the circuit h1
locked out of the game and this is where
the the impressive stuff
uh kind of starts happening so chat how
would you continue with white here
because
i think this is one of the the trickiest
parts of playing an opening
like the king's gambit when your
opponent really does come after you
and says i'm going to keep this pawn you
gave me a free pawn i'm going to keep it
and then i shall have more pawns than
you it can be a little bit difficult
to actually prove that
this central pawn advantage this
development advantage is worth a pawn
you have to do something with it or else
black will slowly
but surely catch back up with moves like
bishop g7
knight a6 knight f6 black is going to be
catching up
if you're not doing something active so
what do you do
what can be done here
okay there's some ideas in the chat uh a
lot of the the players
are looking at this g5 f4
construction here and realizing that
this move h4 could be quite tempting but
h4 while it is a tempting move is going
to have to be a move
you're very very cautious about
so something nobody in the chat room is
mentioning is the idea that was played
in the game
so chat room while your ideas of h4 are
very often good in openings like the
king's gambit
here bobby wants to make use of all of
these pieces
right this knight and this queen in
particular
are not really ready to help out on the
king's side so moves like h4
just from a principled level might not
be the right idea here
for exa for example h4 g4
if you try to go to some square like g5
your knight is actually going to get
trapped on this square and that will
just be a full piece for black
so you would have to in fact come back
to a square like 91 or knight g1
and you're still not quite picking up
this pawn right black is able to
sort of defend this against anything you
might try
so h4 not a bad move by any stretch but
perhaps
g4 in black is still in control here
so what does bobby do well he counters
an attack on the flank with an attack in
the center
right white's big advantage in the
king's gambit
is not that he's always going to be
regaining the pawn on f4
the advantage is you have drawn black's
pawn away from the center
increasing your central presence and
that is what bobby tries to make use of
here
and so uh the best moves in my opinion
are either e5 which was played in the
game
or the move d5 something to make use of
this central
pawn majority and so bobby goes e5 in
this case
now of course with the black pieces here
priority number one
tends to be keeping things a bit closed
when you are playing
you know the role of the green meister
and you want to keep all the material
uh oftentimes you are lagging in
development
as black is here and when you lag in
development you
must must must keep the center closed
right if you're up in development
you want to open the center down in
development you want to
close the center down so here larry of
course does not play d
take c when perhaps now the time is
right for the move h4
when g4 could be met by knight takes e5
but instead plays the natural move d5
you want to keep things closed
in the center and bobby makes a pretty
interesting decision here
um believe it or not this is actually a
pretty difficult choice
for the queen you can either come back
to the center the move like queen d3
or queen e2 or you can go with the
interesting queen
b3 and what's the idea of queen b3 well
you're just sort of inhibiting
black's development a little bit further
because knight d7 would always be met by
queen takes b7 in the game uh bobby
played a little bit more consistently
with his plan of the central control and
goes queen d3
i think queen b3 was a fine move as well
uh black now goes knight a6
still trying to get developed and trying
to highlight that d3 might not be the
safest square for the queen
and now what does bobby do well he's
pushed in the center
gotten this nice little central pawn
wedge with some extra space
inhibiting black's pieces a little bit
especially this bishop in this knight in
particular
and now once again the question becomes
how
can he play for an advantage in this
position
so chat your idea of h4 i'm just going
to give you a hint here
h4 is in fact a good idea for the
position
but the question is how do you make it
work how do you prepare this move
because you don't really want to play h4
and only be sort of attacking the
structure with half your pieces
so how do you actually make this work
that is the question
jeff says we all said e5 i disagree jeff
i was reading i didn't see it
ah okay they they did eventually come up
with e5
uh i must rescind my comment about the
chat room getting
the question wrong
so yeah it's a question of reorganizing
white's pieces
so right now it looks as though opening
things up on the queen side of the board
is
is going to be rather difficult for
white right maybe you go something like
knight e2
and play for c4 but it feels a little
bit artificial this knight is sort of
blocked
from influencing the queen side for the
moment by white's own pawns
however the king side is the direction
where white's pawns kind of point for
the moment
white has this extra pawn on e5 to grant
him more space on this side of the board
and so bobby is looking to play on the
king's side and again
the key break is going to be h4 like the
chat room was mentioning a little bit
earlier
now how do you prepare it well you
simply take the pieces that are on the
queen side
and you bring them to the king's side so
bobby starts with the move knight e2
pressuring f4 also allowing bobby to
sort of defend his center with a move
like c3
black did continue with knight b4 we saw
queen d1
keeping an eye on the c2 pawn and also
as i said
keeping an eye on the king's side of the
board as well
black felt it was time to castle
queenside
uh and then bobby starts with the
natural c3 driving the knight back to a6
and now is the time bobby
has all of his pieces now pointing at
the king's side at least all the pieces
that he can use to point at the king's
side the rooks are a bit harder to
activate
and he decides the moment is right for
the move h4
notably i think this is where larry
evans
started to lose the threat of the
position a little bit he went for this
weird sort of knight a6 knight before
tempo idea
gaining time on the queen but while
larry was busy moving the night around
and castling queenside bobby had very
much organized his entire army towards
the king's side
and i don't think white is really any
worse in this position
before this position maybe white was
doing a little bit worse with black
having this extra pawn
but now bobby's pieces make sense and
black's pieces just don't
g4 is sort of the the only real idea
here you can go
f6 but this is just giving the pawn back
after takes takes
and takes and as we know black's play
thus far
has been to be as greedy as possible and
hang on to this pawn for dear life
so rather than f6 h or g4
is still really the main idea and now
rather than come back to e1 or g1
uh with this extra knight around to help
attack
f4 help guard some squares bobby felt h2
was the correct square
for the knight going after the g4 pawn
as well
uh now with the g4 pawn hanging it's
actually a very very difficult position
for for black to get a hold of so what's
going on here
g4 is hanging f4 is hanging but it turns
out there's one more pawn hanging in the
position
and that is the h4 pawn so this is the
time
in the game when there's no principles
there's no shortcuts this is where chess
becomes a game
for dirty calculators and the the
specifics in this case i think are gonna
work out pretty well for bobby
in in most cases uh larry i think found
a good move here which was h5
and while this does give back the f4
pawn it does cement this pawn on
g4 and by doing that you lock this
knight out of the game for the moment
and it's going to take bobby a few moves
in order to reorganize his pieces again
so knight takes f4 played in the game
and now larry has a decision do you take
on h4 or do you not take on h4
and chat room i'm going to leave it to
you i'll give you a little bit of a hint
here
don't waste too much time sort of
looking at for knockout punches
after clean h4 with some night discovery
because yeah and the ghost is closing
the door to the studio
that really scared me but that's okay um
don't look for
for too many knockout punches after
queen takes h4 i don't think they really
exist
so it's more of a positional question is
it good for black
to capture this pawn on h4 or not
doesn't help
joe says be greedy
school says we don't care about material
we want to attack
the king okay
i don't know what
skull is suggesting though it's fine to
want to attack the king but do you want
to attack the king by taking the pawn or
attack the king some other way
so yeah larry in this case is making uh
the mistake that uh a lot of people in
the chat room
are making not everybody but but a lot
of people uh and that is
so far black has played like the
greediest person alive
and has just captured the pawn tried to
maintain the pawn
tried to get everything he you know
available to him and keep everything
available to him
and so staying consistent with that
larry does capture this pawn in h4
but it turns out that this move does
give white the advantage
why does this move give white the
advantage well it's not any knockout
punch it's not and some crazy e6 idea
some knight takes g4 idea
these ideas simply just just aren't
working right the rook on h1
is hanging for the moment e6 doesn't
doesn't really do enough like if you go
e6
you can just take if you take me back i
have a queen f6
check things like this right um
so there's no knockout punch for for
white but
what there is is now an h file right if
we go back to this position
this piece is out of the game this piece
is out of the game and after knight
takes f4
it's true that these two pieces are
starting to play again
but even the queen is sort of stuck
looking at this pawn
on a on the g4 square
and so with black sort of hold on the
position a little bit
uh that's why black is doing okay here
because
these four pieces in particular are sort
of being
very much contained by black structure
now by playing queen takes h4
you very much open up this rook and
we'll see with bobby's next move
you're going to be activating this
knight as well
and then eventually this this queen as
well all of the white pieces sort of
spring to life
after queen takes h4 what would have
been a better move
well i think it turns out black white
actually does have a threat
for example if you just play some move
like this i think knight takes h5 can be
played
because of queen takes g4 with check
so some simple move like queen d7 sort
of stepping out of
the checking idea on g4 and i think
black is doing okay here
uh what do the next moves look like well
if you try something like king g1
to get this piece in the game now there
are sort of some some crazy ideas here
uh but simple development i think is
going to be okay
for for black here for example knight f1
knight f5 and black is still playing for
this containment idea
just keeping the white pieces at bay and
i don't think black is going to be
better
but i also don't think black is is going
to be worse here right these pieces are
still just a little bit too awkward for
white
to ever really have a serious advantage
so what happens instead well larry gets
greedy
takes a pawn on h4 and now chat white to
move and
oh sorry
uh my fault for using a touchpad there
how dare i touch a touchpad on a laptop
wait to move
and get a very serious advantage it may
have been spoiled by that quick little
scroll
but you'll have to be pretty fast with
your eyes to catch that one i think
white to move and secure an advantage
so yeah it's the simple move here um i
i mentioned it in another line that we
just looked at
but the trick for white is just getting
these pieces active it's all
about the activity in these crazy
openings and the best way to get these
pieces active
is the slightly strange looking king g1
you just vacate the f1 square for the
knight
you defend the rook unpinning the the
knight
as well now knight takes g4 is an actual
threat for example
and uh here white is going to be much
better
black finally decided to develop the
king side and goes knight h6
and this move is to play against the
idea of nay takes g4
when now there's no pin on the h file to
to exploit
but instead bobby just goes knight f1
and
regains this pawn on h5 and so
what do we have well we have a trade of
the h4 pawn for the
h5 pawn and at first glance you might
say well
white's king is on g1 black's king is on
the queen side
why not open the h file but in this case
you have to look at the specifics just
as a game of specifics
and here the specifics favor white right
with the h puns on the board these two
pieces were awful
this queen was also not great with the h
pawns off the board
the rook is active this knight is going
to come into play this queen is very
active
and white is sort of just crushing now
uh
black tries the move rook g8 here which
is sort of just desperately trying to
hang on to the g4 pawn
now white develops out this other knight
once again
we see rook g6 by black and notably
these two pieces just aren't playing in
the game
uh and here the knockout punches start
to come
white brings this knight back to f4 this
rook comes up to g5
and more simple development by bobby
fischer and black has sort of just been
developed to death right white just
spent all of his time
activating his pieces and black is is
now crumbling
uh knight c7 comes on the board finally
rerouting this knights
but queen d2 is piling on the pressure
on this diagonal
the rook comes back to g8 this rook
going
for quite the dance here um knight f
to e2 is bobby fischer's choice uh sorry
not knight g two but knight f to e2
uh and the pressure has now finally
broken through
on this knight which is actually trapped
and so bobby wins this piece on h6
and sort of out of nowhere uh just just
wins the entire game
the game did continue for a few moments
f6 was played
ef queen f bishop takes h6
and black goes bishop d6 with a little
bit of activity
but now all of bobby's pieces are in
game
and bobby has more pieces so queen e6
push it back to f4 d e8's
rook h6 takes takes queen e7
and very very shortly this game was
resigned by larry evans uh just down a
full piece
with no compensation so this i think
is the best example of bobby fischer
uh playing with more activity right
this is the game that bobby proved he
was the person who could improve his
pieces the best
right he played against the greed
meister larry evans and came out on top
larry tried to hold on to everything
take everything control everything but
you just
can't always do like play like that you
have to make some concessions in chess
there's a very famous quote that says
chess is a game of give and take
and that's that's very much true to to
get something you have
to give something and in this case larry
tried to get all of the material gains
uh but he gave bobby fischer a bit too
much
activity and that activity came to uh
came to bite
larry evans all right any questions on
this game
before i move on to a little bit of a
shorter one
all right let us continue then
up next wow the first game may look
pretty brilliant there were a lot of
games
that could uh potentially be deserving
of a brilliancy prize
uh most people cite this next game when
they talk about
bobby fischer playing brilliant chess in
this championship of course
they cite a lot of games but this is the
game that that sort of stands out
and it's a game against robert byrne not
the only burn
in the championship this year there was
also a donald byrne
which did confuse me a little bit to be
honest i'm not the greatest chess
historian i was like wait
bob you played burn twice but no they
were different people uh but okay let's
just jump into it here
we'll see what robert byrne played
against robert james
fisher we had d4 knight f6
c4 g6 by bobby
g3 c6 bishop g2 and d5
cd5 cd5 knight c3 and bishop g7
so what do we have in this position well
we have bobby going for this fiance
setup and then we have in
a very interesting structure in the
center the c pawns have been traded off
leaving only these d pawns sitting on on
d4 and
d5 and what is the character of this
structure
well normally it's it's a pretty boring
one you get this structure from openings
like the exchange slav
but there is a very interesting thing
going on here which is that both sides
have committed to fianchettoing their
bishops
what does this mean well in this setup
usually the pawn on d4 and the pawn on
d5
they're both pretty solid right both
sides may potentially play moves like e3
and e6 and with that both of these
bishops are really going to be stunted
on their fiancee squares these tend to
just be bad pieces
in this structure from my experience so
keep an eye out during this game for
potential ideas
for bobby to activate this bishop on g7
and for burn
to try and activate the bishop on g2
it's going to be interesting to see
their different approach
to uh this problem in the game white
does just start with the move e3 very
directly defending the d4 pawn
and saying i'm going to lock your bishop
out of the game now bobby took a little
bit of a different approach
did not respond with the move e6 but
just castled the king
we see knight g to e2 by white
and perhaps now white is trying to
activate this bishop
using the pieces hinting and that this
knight might come out to f4
and white is going to try to pile up on
this d5 pawn
meanwhile black plays knight c6 we see
castles
by black sorry it castles by white
and now the problem of the bishops is
solved by both players
there's not too much of a future to be
honest on this diagonal for the bishop
keep in mind that the sometimes common
idea of trying to trade off
the light squared bishops on h3 just
doesn't make sense here right this is
something that i've seen actually in a
lot
of like amateur games even slightly
higher level
games as well in positions like this it
makes
no sense to trade off these light
squared bishops this
is a bad piece this is not a good piece
just because it's being cut out
doesn't mean it's a good piece it's a
bad piece staring
at a d5 pawn and so
why should black try you know so so hard
to to get rid of it and the answer is
you just shouldn't
you just shouldn't uh in this case bobby
fischer manages to find a more useful
square for this bishop making it
potentially even more useful
than the bishop on g2 how does he do
that well he goes b6
white responds in kind with b3 but now
bobby brings the bishop out to a6
and it's very clear which bishop uh you
know
is is doing more work here in fact you
know i wouldn't be surprised if
white would very much later in the game
try to trade off this bishop
on on f1 white responds in kind though
and goes bishop a3 and now it's it's a
question
of how do you actually make any tangible
progress
in this position and it's a question i'm
going to ask the chat room
once again so you've developed all the
minor pieces
we now have this one openc file
how do you actually improve your pieces
in this game
so don't just give me a move here give
me a plan
to improve the pieces
and yeah pip and chuck has uh something
along
the right idea you know everybody wanted
to play rookie 8 to
unpin the e pawn but the idea in this
case for bobby
is not necessarily to just go e6 going
for the same sort of conservative
stunting of the bishop for white but
bobby is interested in activating his
own bishop
on g7 so the idea here is rook
e8 white responded with queen d2
and now bobby makes the the very
committal decision to push this pawn not
to e6 but all the way
to e5 and what we're going to see is
that
this is sort of a game of give and take
once again for bobby fischer
in this case bobby is giving white the
better structure
of course after d takes e5 this pawn
is going to be a bit weak what is bobby
getting in exchange for it
well active uh an active piece on g7
and an active square for this knight on
e5
so once again bobby turns out to uh to
be
playing this this sort of game of give
and take at just a higher level
than his opponents uh because i do think
this was
just a good position now for black right
you know rookie eight
and all all the black's pieces are
spring to life
we do see knight takes e5 by black
and it's a bit too early to go capturing
this pawn because
this white queen is just a little bit
overworked for example takes
takes and sorry there's even knight f3
check here as well but
this is the tactic that i saw when of
course
black would be winning so a bit too
early to be capturing on d5 so
tactically this is working
out and then
robert byrne makes a mistake believe it
or not
makes a mistake so the most natural move
in the position
in my opinion is to bring a rook to the
d1 square
you can go rook a d1 or you can go rook
fd1
and it's very very important which rook
goes to d1
so chat room which rook goes to the d1
square
so yeah great wolf has an interesting
question that we'll come back to but
then
remind me if i forget but i will come
back to that but let's focus on this one
for now
and as always the mysterious rook moves
are somewhat splitting the chat although
it does appear that rook 81
is slightly in the lead for the moment
amongst the the chat
uh rogeft one making a comeback though a
lot of seeing a lot of f's in the chats
and it turns out the a rook
is the correct rook to to bring to d1
but
the the reason as to why is so
so deep and so subtle that you you can't
blame burn
for for moving the f rook in my opinion
the most natural move
is actually the move rook f to d1 why is
that the most natural
well this really great bishop on a6 is
sort of just
uh bearing down on this rook it's
pinning this knight it's a bit
uncomfortable right
so whitewood would love to be able to
play rook f to d1
as he did in the game however it turns
out rook a to d1 is better
why is that well after a get to d1 black
uh sort of unleashes just a a very wild
series of moves here
uh bobby fischer starts with knight d3
and
seemingly this is just just a bad move
uh right
seemingly this this move is just pretty
bad why is this move pretty bad well you
put the knight on d3 it looks great
there
but after queen c2 this knight is
attacked twice
and how do you actually escape so so
chat
what was bobby's idea your knight is
attacked twice if you think you're just
going to move back here you're going to
find your d-pawn
is hanging what to do with black
seemingly a bad move
and yeah of course you know once you see
this position
uh and you see that there's actually no
other options you sort of
run into run into knight takes f2 by
force and
this was bobby fischer's idea from afar
here which is pretty incredible
uh pretty incredible to see all right
coming up with knight d3 knight takes f2
is definitely
not easy uh so you know white
white needs to take this knights and he
does
what's the follow-up well of course it's
knight g4
check the king comes back to g1 and
knight takes e3
attacking queen rook and bishop the
queen moves out of the way
and here i did see some notes
on the game but uh apparently burn
at this moment was pondering why
bobby fischer chose this line because it
seems as though
you know it might just be good for white
right like you take this rook on d1
you get rick takes d1 and for the moment
white is holding everything together
white has two pieces for the rook and
two pawns
but this d-pawn is going to be very weak
right and you know
not that black is losing here but but
why
would bobby fischer choose this line and
okay the chat's a bit ahead of me on
this one
the idea is not knight takes d1 the idea
of course
is knight takes g2
and this apparently is the point of
bobby fischer's play
thus far uh this move knight takes g2
uh you know for all my words about this
bishop on g2 being a very bad piece
it did serve one very useful purpose and
that purpose was defending the king
now that purpose is is not so
so easy to fill with the bishop off the
board uh king takes g2
played and then the the nice follow-up
here for bobby fischer
is just a simple removal of the defender
of this knight on e2
right we would love to play rook take c2
and win the game but this knight is in
the way
and so bobby plays d4 um
seemingly though still under control for
white i don't have to move this knights
and burn plays knight takes d4 instead
and bobby just gives a little check
i'll give you this move and then who can
guess
the final move of the game here the
final move of the game
i i suspect pippen chuck has seen the
game before
in the chat
uh queen f6 in rook 8 d8 has been
suggested by
by grey wolf oh and i'm messing things
up okay
uh of course it is a very famous game um
yeah queen f6
is okay uh queen f4 would likely be the
answer
and i'm gonna you know sort of break
the fourth wall here a little bit uh
there's a lot of history around the game
where everybody is is writing about
these two you know commentators over the
game two unnamed grand masters
sort of leaning back explaining to to
the crowd
uh yet now byrne is simply up a piece
and he will go on to win the game
and after fischer's next move queen d7
uh
byrne actually resigns and supposedly
the commentators were telling you know
they're uh they're spectators that yes
okay queen d7 and bobby has resigned
burn has won the game uh of course after
queen d7 it was
byrne who resigned and fisher who won
and while this is a great story i
i actually find myself to be a little
bit skept skeptical of it
why is that well black is winning with
many many moves here uh rook c8
is just a very very simple move but it's
a move that highlights the fact
that white really can't move uh his
pieces right you can't even move this
knight
um because queen f6 check and it's just
it's just domination at this point like
bobby fischer's is just crushing here
queen c8 wins the game queen d7 wins the
game queen c7 wins the game bishop a6 is
fine for black
even doing nothing playing playing the
move h5 in this position is
is good for black so i'm a little bit
skeptical about this story where two
unnamed grandmasters are evaluating this
position as winning for burn and bobby
fischer resigns but
it is you know a nice story regardless
of how
of how true it is um in the game
bobby fischer did not play queen f6 but
the very very accurate queen
to d7 now what is the point well the
point is
we are coming after the king with queen
h3 check
what is the point of that well let's say
white plays a very good defensive move
like queen f2
uh then queen h3 check would still come
king g won
and who sees the knockout blow here
black to move
and win the game
black to move and win the game
and yes it is in fact not bishop d4
first bishop d4 first would be a big
mistake go bishop d4
rook takes d4 and white is defending and
winning
but you first go rookie one check and
this
is the nice distraction sacrifice
if queen takes rook then queen g2 is
mate and if rook takes rook
then bishop takes d4 and again the queen
is being distracted
from her very important role of guarding
against checkmate on g2 if you take this
this is mate if you go rookie three
doesn't help i just take that anyways
and so white here would be dead
in the water simply nothing to be done
here for uh
for burn which is why he resigned after
queen d7 um
instead of playing queen f2 it would
have been nice to see it appear on the
board
but bern had seen enough he was like get
get me out of this game get me out of
this game
uh and yeah as ignacio is saying in the
chat
the most impressive fact is that this
attack seemingly came out of nowhere
but really did it come out of nowhere uh
i think
well of course you know it's easy to say
the move with the game is knight d3
knight takes f2
i think this game was positionally
uh winning by fischer with this move e5
now was
was white winning uh sorry was black
winning on the board after e5 i don't
think so
but e5 showed that bobby had a deeper
understanding of this give and take
in chess with the move e5 he understood
that the activity
he was getting was better than the
structural weakness that he was giving
and that
is really where the the uh the top of
the top
separate themselves from their
competition it's moves like e5
that do it right any any old 2750 can
calculate knight d3 knight takes f2
okay maybe they can't but even if they
could
i don't think many 2750s have this deep
understanding
about playing for e5 in positions like
this uh even if they do today
back then i think this sort of just
native intuition
for when you can make these positional
sacrifices
for active activity gains is is very
very strange
um great wolf did have a question
earlier though about specifically i
think this move b6 so
this bishop of course has this open
diagonal here that it can develop out
uh develop out to and so he was asking
well so why why would you play b6 here
why open a second diagonal for the
bishop
when the bishop already has one diagonal
available
and that comes down to a few different
things first and foremost the most
important thing to keep in mind
is the squares that you that you're
weakening
and secondly if you can afford to spend
the time to do it if this was some wild
and crazy opening where every tempo
mattered
then a move like b6 would likely be very
bad in this case
it's not it's just total symmetry and
white is not exactly making
too many immediate threats so the move
b6 is fine
by by the time spent and it's not like
you know the moves you see by whites g3
and e3 which are actually
weakening the light squares here so that
is why black can play like this now
why does black play like this well the
advantage is this diagonal is simply
much more important than any diagonal
over here
on the king's side of the board right
it's so much more valuable
to be putting this pressure on this
knight in this rook and controlling as
well
this d3 square as we saw in the game so
any other questions
on this game
if carlson was white after the move e5
by black could he defend
i don't i i don't know maybe probably
but magnus carlsen was not white in the
game
[Music]
where did white go wrong well for one
this this was a pretty timid opening as
far as openings go
this is about as timid as they come by
white
and then beyond that i think all of
these moves
were honestly fine by by white i think
if white goes with ad1 here
white is is probably still doing okay
all right black does have a little bit
of this extra activity
but white does have this nice structural
advantage
and given a few more moves if white gets
something like knight f4
challenging this pawn or even knight d4
just black hating and holding the
position
then i think white is is going to be
doing okay so rick fd1
then after knight d3 it's still not too
late to not lose the game
white could have played something like
knight to uh to f4 and this definitely
keeps the game going although black is
probably going to be
be much better right just defending f2
is the the important thing to spot here
um okay
if burn had played the a rook to d1 he
wouldn't have fallen to such disaster
well you know it's it's always a game of
what if if white played rook a to d1
maybe he would have made a mistake later
in the game uh but
objectively white is not really doing
that badly after rook a to d1
although black is by no means worse
thanks to this activity of his pieces
but okay let us move along
uh let's check out now a little bit of a
different game by bobby fischer his
opponent in this game
is william addison which as i've said
before i'm not the greatest
chess historian in the world but i think
addison is one of those names
that might have shown up in a few u.s
championships but he wasn't exactly
winning winning too many of them uh so
addison maybe a little bit of a bigger
underdog
than everyone else uh when playing bobby
fischer but
we'll see here that he did manage to put
up a very nice fight
and so i wanted to analyze this game
because
you know in the first game we saw bobby
fischer defending well
and playing for activity in the second
game we saw bobby fischer
sort of making something out of nothing
he took a symmetrical position
and still managed to activate his pieces
and now i want to look at
a slightly more of a positional grind
uh right as i've said in order to go
11-0 you sort of have to be
you know better than your opponents in
every aspect of chess and this i think
is an aspect that we we hadn't yet
seen by bobby so far in the event so
let's take a look at it
uh addison starts with the move e4 we
get e5
knight f3 knight c6 and it's a roy lopez
we get a6 bishop a4 and bobby goes for
this line with the immediate b5
and this is sort of uh an early
concession
almost by black the idea of the roy is
sort of
to draw these black pawns forward so
that a little bit later
on they can sort of be exploited for
their weaknesses
but it's a very common opening variation
still
uh so bishop b3 and the point of black's
play with drawing these pawns so far out
is to immediately
go after this bishop so we get knight a5
and then white didn't play the main move
here these days i think castles is the
most common but white immediately broke
in the center
with the move of d4 bobby now
has to sort of deal with this threat to
the e5 pawn and so we see e takes d4 in
the game
queen takes d4 now play it as well
and bobby develops out with knight e7
which is
sort of not the move that would come to
mind for many people
right off the bat but it's it's a
perfectly sensible move
uh bobby likely didn't want to come out
to f6 for
fear of this e pawn stepping out to e5
when this knight is
just a little bit stuck so 97 instead
bobby is just
finding another way to get developed
white
played the move c3 which is making a
threat that threat is to save this
bishop
and so now bobby does go ahead and
capture on b3
we get a takes b3 bishop b7 bobby still
just continuing to develop the pieces
bishop f4
and now black is ready to sort of take
over the game i think maybe
bishop f4 was a bit on the lacks side
by by william addison here so
black to move and start playing for the
advantage
already
and yes the chassis historians are
thankfully in the chat even if they're
not on the
stream and i'm being told addison played
in five u.s championships
did fairly well and was the respected
american master and that was sort of the
feeling i got
um i i think he was you know definitely
on the scene
at the top of the country but uh you
know
sort of born in a time where
there were some very very good chess
players in the united states
perhaps got a little bit overshadowed
so yeah the the thing to do here with
black is a little bit
actually counter-intuitive um i think
sort of the safe way to play is to go
something like knight g6
perhaps this is one reason why putting
the bishop on f4 was a little bit
lacks it allows black to sort of gain
this tempo something like bishop g3
perhaps
and then you can even just play
something like bishop b7 and develop
your pieces
and be living life although i might be
hanging
upon right but if something like bishop
g5 for example
then i think you can go something like
this should be seven with the point
that after this stuff that the e pawn
would be hanging so
bishop g3 or something and then black
should still try to get developed and
you can do so with something like c5
and again playing bishop e7 uh in the
near future
i think that would have been fine for
black but what bobby does is
you know immediately strikes back in the
center with the move d5
and as far as a principled explanation
as to why this
is sort of working out for bobby it's
not immediately apparent
right bobby is further away from getting
castled than white is
so why is he justified in actually
opening up the center here
well i think it's because of this move
bishop f4 once again bishop f4
while it looks like a very active square
for the bishop is actually creating of
course a loose
piece and we all know that loose pieces
start to lead
to tactics for uh for the opponent and
in this case now if e takes d5
we probably would have seen knight takes
d5 and
white is just feeling a little bit
uncomfortable about having this bishop
here
on the f4 square if you castle this will
definitely be captured
by uh by black if you check 96 so you
have to take
now bishop e7 and castles and bobby is
is doing pretty well here
why is he doing pretty well here well
you've got two bishops a wide open
center
and black should definitely have some
advantage
so uh it's because of this bishop on
f4 that black is able to play d5 white
is going to have to spend some time
to deal with this threat to the bishop
on f4 for example something like
bishop g3 and then it's actually going
to be black
who is exploiting the open e file before
white with moves like queen e7 check
moves like c5 queen e7
as well and that's why d5 is working for
black so what's the moral of the story
uh the moral of the story is try not to
make loose pieces and when your opponent
makes loose pieces
look to to sort of exploit that any way
you can in this case
knight g6 exploiting the loose piece
would gain time for black
and d5 opening up the center is playable
and good for black
because this bishop on f4 is so loose
now if white had played a move
like bishop like kingside castles for
example
then i think d5 is going to be a little
bit harder to
to prove anything with for for black for
example if d5
ed5 now knight takes d5 simply isn't
really playable
because this file is just too wide open
so what is that what is the point of all
that the point again
is loose pieces are bad don't make them
loose pieces
are awful so d5 by bobby fischer and
then
addison felt that the time was right to
play e5 not willing
to give this knight the d5 square and
taking a bit more central space
now bobby finds the correct idea once
again which is still
sort of exploiting this bishop on
on f4 with the move c5 now if queen
takes c5
uh guess what there is a winning tactic
here
so chatroom black to move and win after
queen takes c5
so knight g6 ninja 6 doesn't quite work
actually
uh it's tempting to try to somehow
combine
this queen with the weakness of the
bishop but the queen can retreat to
defend
and yeah the chat room has got it now
knight f5 is
miraculously somehow trapping the queen
in the center of the board
all of the squares are simply defended
uh and so yeah that would be the game
that's that
so after c5 uh perhaps this is what
addison
missed by the way because if black
doesn't play c5 here
white is going to play the move b4 uh
very very very quickly
and sort of put a stop to any c5 ideas
but in the game c5 was not missed
fischer found it we see the queen come
back to d3
and now we do still see knight g6 and
white continues to pay for putting this
bishop on f4 with losing yet another
tempo
in the form of bishop g3 black develops
now with bishop b7
we have knight b to d2 and now
we see a very interesting idea by
fischer
so black to move in this case and come
up with a plan
black to move and come up with a plan
what do you think chat because i'm not
going to lie to you
this one i think is is pretty incredible
by
bobby fischer this one is pretty
incredible
this one is pretty incredible in my
opinion
so there are a lot of good ideas in the
chat
and it does turn out this is one of
those positions where it's
difficult to decide where to play right
you have all of this space
already on the queen side of the board
and you want to maintain that you don't
want to push it too
far though because white does have some
weaknesses back here but you sort of
want to maintain this this nice central
space regarding all these squares
you'd like to somehow maybe blockade or
attack this pawn
but beyond that it's it's not super
clear how to advance
maybe this break of d4 as has been
mentioned in the chat is going to be a
critical one to open up this bishop
open up the d file as well and so d4 is
definitely going to be on black's mind
but bobby actually does something really
really interesting
i think a lot a lot a lot of players
would castle here
and i don't think castles is a bad move
at all but
bobby manages to apply a little bit more
pressure to
addison here by first going that f8
allowing white to castle
and then knight e6 uh with this is just
a very natural rerouting of the knight
e6 blockades this pawn prepares the the
break of d4
and then after rook a to d1 does
something pretty incredible right again
i would probably castle nine times out
of ten here but bobby fischer says
look my king is safe right here this
pawn is not going anywhere i have good
control of the center
i am going to go g5 and take space
on the king's side as well and
a lot of times you know this this comes
with drawbacks right it weakens squares
it gives your opponent chances for
counter play
but taking space like this is a really
effective way to put some pressure on
the opponent right when you're facing
down pawns
on g5 and after h3 pawns on h5
as well all of a sudden you're still
calculating ideas of g4
you're still calculating ideas of maybe
a5 a4
some days even c4 b4 all of these breaks
and now you're also thinking about g4
right and it's just not easy when your
opponent is sort of coming after you
on all sides of the board like this that
being said
it does make some weaknesses and does
come with some risk so
word of warning if you want to use this
in your own games you're probably going
to lose some games if you start doing h5
g5 but
probably also going to win some games
bobby followed this up with queen b6
which is just an improving move for the
queen
getting the queen off of the same file
as this rook perhaps preparing a move
like rick d8 if necessary
and then after net f1 a natural
improving move
for white bobby decided it was go
time he has the pieces where he wants
them
and he doesn't really want to see this
knight landing on the f5 square
so he does break through now with the
move of d4
of course after cd4 cd4 this pawn
is not really hanging thanks to the idea
of rook d8
so d4 played in the game and then we
actually see
addison start to start to crumble a
little bit
addison plays the move knight 3 to d2
and this one is a little bit beyond me
to be honest i'm not entirely sure
what's uh what you know what the idea
was here
you get the feeling that that he wanted
to do something like knight e4
and putting a knight on f6 or d6 but why
not use this knight why did this knight
go to f1
if you're putting this knight on d2 it
just didn't make a lot of sense to me
and this move does turn out to be a bit
of a mistake
um bobby now continues playing all sides
of the board with the move g4
white goes h4 and now queen c6
and it's it's pretty clear what's uh
what's going on here
um and actually yeah i'm sorry i should
mention knight d2 does have the benefit
of
stepping out of the way of this idea of
g4 but again
i just don't think it was very good
because a lot of times
uh after something like g4 like let's
say
this knight came to d2 you want to
actually put this knight on h4 instead
and again head into the f5 square so
queen c6 and white tries to go queen e4
to trade off the queens and now bobby
actually doesn't shy away from this
just castles queen side takes takes
and we have a queen list position now
why is bobby so fine with entering this
this queenless position
well it's something called the principle
of two
weaknesses white has sort of a general
weakness on the queen side
these b pawns are often going to be weak
and thanks to this expansion on the
king's side
bobby is understanding that he's making
more weaknesses
over here and these are just too many
weaknesses
for white to really keep together in the
game
c4 was played king d7
simply improving the king a little bit
and allowing the rook's access to the
queen side of the board
rook a1 rook a8 to defend knight e4
takes takes now knight g7 and it's clear
that white is not going to be able to
keep these pawns together
and this pawn together all at the same
time
knight d2 is played now knight f5 and
things start to drop
rook f4 king e6 just keeping
everything solid knight e4 takes on c4
takes on c4 rook b8s and now once again
weakness on the queen side weakness on
the king side and even a weakness in the
center for white
and this is just simply way too much for
white to hold together
rook a2 rook b4 was played going after
the c pawn as well
knight d2 just defending but bobby does
now collect this pawn
on h4 and the game ends very shortly
rook e4 bishop g5 going after the knight
f4
takes takes check and another pawn for
black
and addison decided to throw in the
towel here
so what is this game show well it showed
that uh bobby fischer
was playing very excellent positional
chess as
well this is a classic example of black
sort of making a weakness early on on
the queen side
but then rather than playing simple
moves like king side castles that i
think many many players would play
bobby went for more and managed to
create a second weakness on the king
side for white to deal with
and thanks to that he was able to
convert this game very very cleanly
and pretty easily as well well i guess
bobby always makes it look easy
obviously it wasn't that easy but you
know
he was able to do it that is going to do
it for
uh this lecture here on the road to 2000
up next i am actually going to look at a
few
really key end games from this same
tournament that bobby went 11-0 at
uh and that's going to be coming up on
in the end game class
that i think ben has has linked in the
chat already so
please do join me there but for the road
to 2000
that is all for tonight thank you guys
so much for watching and i will see you
next time
[Music]
you